99% of people delete their entire password
and start over if they mess up just one letter.
Buckingham Palace has 602 rooms.
The largest sperm bank in the world does not
accept donations from redheads because of
'insufficient demand'.
Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg only eats
meat from animals he has killed himself.
Reno, Nevada is farther west than Los Angeles,
California.
Sigurd the Mighty, a ninth-century Norse earl
of Orkney, was killed by an enemy he had beheaded
several hours earlier.
He'd tied the man's head to his horse's saddle,
but while riding home one of its protruding
teeth grazed his leg.
He died from the infection.
Insects outnumber humans 100 million to one.
A blue whales heart only beats nine times
per minute.
Some fruit flies are genetically resistant
to getting drunk — but only if they have
an inactive version of a gene scientists have
named “happyhour”.
Americans spend more on dog food every year
than they spend on baby food.
When male fruit flies are given alcohol they
develop homosexual tendencies.
Your body paralyzes itself when you sleep
to keep you from acting out your dreams.
St George is the patron saint of England,
leprosy and syphilis.
Hair is made from the same substance as fingernails.
When Columbus apparently 'discovered' the
New World, there were at least 50 million
people living in the Americas.